what a night last night I don't even
know really where to start
certainly going to talk about the drama
we were involved in with CNN because of
last night's debate but before I get to
that let's just talk about the debate
itself I am going to say things that
might shock you about Marianne
Williamson performance last night given
what I said about her a couple of weeks
ago but before we get to that we were
wondering in terms of the debate in
general night one debate to last night
would Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren together be bad for the
progressive wing of the Democratic Party
or would it be good my thought was that
it would be good and indeed it was very
very very good Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders last night completely
dominated the first night of the second
presidential debate they did a
stunningly good job of making it clear
that they are not the radicals their
ideas are not the ideas outside of the
mainstream and that opposing their ideas
is increasingly what's radical which was
exactly my hope my idea was when I had
had a video answer I did a about this
last week my idea was that having both
of them up on the stage together rather
than each as the lone sort of strong
progressive on two different stages that
having them together would create the
idea that there is this very strong well
thought out of mature contingent of the
Democratic primary that is adults in the
room with serious well thought out ways
to accomplish the more progressive ideas
that have been mainstreamed over the
last couple of years which includes
health care inequality taxation the
military tuition free college or college
paid for through taxation and both of
them on the stage together did exactly
that Warren and Bernie had number one a
strong coalition of the progressive part
of the Democratic Party and number two
they had a bunch of what I called debate
kill shots and I hate that this is how
debates are evaluated but both of them
had good ones the format of these
debates
sadly doesn't allow
for depth because there's too many
candidates the answers are too short and
the topics are too wide in one evening
to really go in depth there should be
the ideal thing would be five candidates
for an hour and a half just on economics
five candidates for an hour and a half
just on foreign policy it's not what we
had so you've got to look at who had
these kill shots and both Bernie and
Warren came prepared and their biggest
victory was making the point that their
ideas should be the norm not the
exception let's look at a few of these
moments one such moment was when John
Delaney started playing the role of the
enlightened pragmatist who isn't going
to fall for the unrealistic ideas of
Elizabeth Warren or Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren shut it down take a
look so I think when we run on real
solutions not impossible promises when
we run on things that are workable not
fairytale economics you know I don't
understand why anybody goes to all the
trouble of running for president of the
United States just to talk about what we
really can't do and shouldn't fight for
another instance Bernie Sanders straight
up telling Jake Tapper your question is
a right wing talking point which sadly
was too common last night I'm gonna
delve more into that this was just a
very good move by Bernie Jake Tapper
asking candidates if they're in favor of
increasing taxes on the middle class to
pay for Medicare for all
and Bernie said Jake that's a Republican
talking point and by the way for-profit
health care companies are advertising on
CNN right now Jake your question is a
Republican talking point at the end of
the day by the way and by the way by the
way the health care industry will be
advertising tonight on this program you
Center senator Warren it's your turn
oh can I complete
[Applause]
tonight with that talking point senator
Warren Elizabeth Warren said in no
uncertain terms that white supremacy has
to be called domestic terrorism yes this
is fantastic I've been saying this for
years and it should be called domestic
terrorism and there were a lot of zeros
and ones on yesterday's debate stage who
were desperate because they know this is
their last shot to make it into the
third debate in early September in the
middle of September they need at least
2% in four different polls plus a
hundred and thirty thousand total donors
with no fewer than 400 donors from each
of 20 states so a lot of these zeros and
ones went in thinking I'm just gonna
pick a fight with anybody I can pick a
fight with Delaney with Warren was one
example here's Tim Ryan trying to get
one over on Bernie Sanders on Medicare
for all and Bernie doesn't have a second
of it he shuts it right down things they
will be better because Medicare for all
is comprehensive
it covers all healthcare needs for
senior citizens it will finally include
dental care hearing aids and eyeglasses
but you don't second of all I wrote the
damn boom Bernie also by the way like
Warren calling out the people who say we
can't do all of this stuff take a look
at that I get a little bit tired of
Democrats afraid of big ideas
Republicans are not afraid of big ideas
they could give a trillion dollars in
tax breaks to billionaires and
profitable corporations they could bail
out the crooks on Wall Street so please
don't tell me that we cannot take on the
fossil fuel industry and nothing happens
unless we do that the theme here was
number one
Bernie + Warren clearly developing the
soul sort of elder statesman progressive
wing status within this Democratic
primary that's a really good thing
showing the strength of the progressive
movement and of progressive ideas making
those who oppose their ideas look quite
frankly very uninformed and very
ignorant another theme was sadly
terrible moderate
and Bernie called out that one question
as a Republican talking point there were
actually many of these questions when
they were talking about paying for
college through taxes some candidates
want to pay for two years associate's
degree like I think Beto O'Rourke
some candidates want to do for years but
tuition only whereas other candidates
have the idea of more comprehensive room
and board and books and fees even which
are quite high being covered through
taxation but invariably this thing comes
up about if there's free college for
everyone you're also paying for free
college for rich kids who we don't need
to be paying for some of the Dems sort
of agreed with that actually I think Amy
Klobuchar going from memory didn't
immediately shut down that concern as
she should have this is a silly
distraction and it's the fault of the
moderators and to some degree the
Democratic candidates could have done a
better job of exposing the question is
problematic this was in yesterday I did
my 20/20 anti playbook for Democrats
what not to do if you're trying to
defeat Donald Trump don't get involved
in losing debates every social welfare
program has some free riders either
people who don't really need the benefit
but are getting it anyway and or people
who are lying in order to get a benefit
they shouldn't actually qualify for in
this particular case with quote free
college but what we really mean is
college paid for through tax revenues
that are connected the very rich kids
are likely not even interested in going
to the state schools that would be
tuition free under these plans we're
talking about a tiny fraction of the
money that such a plan would cost we
don't need to worry about it that's just
the reality Harvard and Yale aren't
covered by these plans we're talking
about state public colleges and
universities it is a distraction from
the huge stimulative effect and huge
value that would come from people not
coming out of college in crazy student
loan debt you come out of college and
crazy student loan debt you are paying
interest to banksters that's not
economically stimulative if you come out
of college without student loan debt yes
college may have been paid for partially
or fully through taxation you are
immediately taking your wages and
contributing them back into the economy
not to banksters but to local businesses
and in ways that are actually
economically stimulative instead of
interest paid to big banks so that was
just again the the framing of the debate
completely wrong now I also have to
drastically change my view about
Marianne Williamson and I know that some
people are worried about that because
they're like no no your view last week
was the right one
Marianne Williamson is very quirky she
has no shot she has the background as a
New Age guru which I am not a fan of but
she actually did really well last night
because she stayed away mostly from her
woowoo New Age stuff Bernie and Warren
definitely won the debate we could argue
about who did better than the other
could go either way but Marianne
Williamson performance was clearly the
third-place performance he or she is
Wacka Lee talking about a dark psychic
force but she actually sounds quite
strong here and gets a good reaction if
you think any of this wall teenis is
going to deal with this dark psychic
force of the collectivized hatred that
this president is bringing up in this
country then I'm afraid that the
Democrats are going to see some very
dark days we need to say it like it is
it's bigger than flint it's all over
this country it's particularly people of
color it's particularly people who do
not have the money to fight back and if
the Democrats don't start saying it then
why would those people feel that they're
there for us and if those people don't
feel
listen she seems to always be on the
edge of claiming that we will solve our
problems by holding crystals but she was
actually quite strong yesterday in her
presentation
she's polling 0.3 percent I don't know
what it's gonna do for her but she at
least put in a good performance and
there was this just general deficit of a
format that really allows deep
conversation and in playing the game
Marianne Williamson did well for herself
that being said she's wacky and people
get mad at me for saying this people ask
me what I mean check out just one
example okay in one of her books she
says sickness is not a sign of God's
judgement but of our judgment on
ourselves we get sick if we judge
ourselves and then she later says in the
same page that sickness is merely an
illusion that doesn't exist her 2010
weight-loss book recommends sage
cleansing your kitchen and praying
yourself thin and she once tweeted God
his big swine flu small see every cell
of your body filled with divine light
pour God's love on our immune systems
truth protects this is insanity it's
insanity but she's funny in the debates
and I liked her presence and the crowd
was reacting positively to her and she
was clearly in third place and I guess I
would say Buddha judge sort of able to
tread water and do okay in some spots I
would say putative Lee in fourth place
although I don't know how much it will
do with him tent up for him tonight we
have Biden with a bunch of other people
I will be streaming live commentary on
twitch at twitch.tv slash David Pakman I
hope you will follow me there and next I
want to talk about why I will be
streaming on Twitch